the other way we can defeat this thing
not only by being a little bit better
and not telling everybody to f off is do
some of this fight a little of this with
canonical asexual no with humor and
that's exactly what Roseanne did
yesterday on Piers Morgan's show now
listen Roseanne let me ask you the most
difficult question in the world
apparently what is a woman
how much do I weigh
no what is a woman
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breaths hang down to her stomach and who
has a prolapsed uterus from giving birth
to five ungrateful little bastards who
have never had to work for a thing in
their goddamn life that's what a woman
is
I'd like to give a special shout out to
Jake who's Roseanne's son who I used to
do some work with who's a good dude Jake
how are you I know you worked
occasionally every now and again
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]